attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
comme c'est ça oui c'est ça mais vous
étiez pas agent immobilier ou avant si
si mais je fais un peu de vtc aussi à
pour arrondir les fins de mois
ah oui c'est pas pour le plaisir de
conduire des mecs bourrés à 3h du mat il
ya des gens qui ont vomi déjà dans votre
voiture
aweys est juste et réelle moi là je veux
faire le tout alors allez-y vous voulez
écouter une radio en particulier
oui je viens écouter la radio de rock
s'il vous plaît non j'aime pas le rock
on va mettre la radio de sport voilà
c'est ma femme qui appelle voilà le
shérif ouais des villes avec qui j la
petite fait l'appartement tout pourrait
que j'arrivais pas à refourguer où est
le pigeon est basse et lui il est
derrière la sur la banquette braves a
dit je te rappelle plus tard allez
bisous
vous voulez des bonbons il y en a dans
l'accoudoir ces bonbons à la menthe ou
des gueux qui colle aux dents si vous
allez pas mais des chamallows non plus
le but c'est pas que les gens les mange
c'est qu'ils pensent que je suis gentil
pareil le bouteilles d'eau s'est terminé
1 donc vous avez retiré tout ce qui est
sympa quoi on va bien et que vous avez
soif
faites vous plaisir monsieur vous êtes
arrivé c'est pas l'adresse que je vous
ai donné mais je vais pas me faire chier
c'est galère après il ya un sens
interdit c'est plus facile à pied vous
marchez cinq minutes vous prenez à
droite à gauche et à une pharmacie on
sait juste après moi ça m'arrange pas si
j'ai pris un vtc c'est pour tout le
monde voit que j'ai un chauffeur qui
m'ont vu la portière les gens sont pas
qu'on voit très bien vous n'avez pas les
moyens d'avoir un réchauffeur mon
commentaire je vous mets trois étoiles
sur cinq
c'est vrai merci moi je me serais mis
deux journées c'est moi qui ai pété
[Musique]